what is forthcoming in terms of criminal
charges for former president Donald
Trump we are really getting into the
meat of this now as we see criminal
referrals from the January 6 house
committee the Georgia investigation the
tax returns possibly exposing tax fraud
and evasion are coming out within days
there is one opinion that is an
interesting one which is from former
Watergate prosecutor Nick Ackerman who
expects Donald Trump to face both state
and federal charges what would happen if
that took place we will discuss but
first let's look at what Nick acreman
had to say on CNN yesterday and his
production predictions are very clear
and they sound confident now remember
many times people say things confidently
and they're wrong so take that uh
consideration what do you think happens
that's what everyone wants to know
Donald Trump is going to be indicted
he's going to be indicted in Georgia and
I think he's going to be indicted by the
feds I think they've got the evidence we
don't know exactly what a lot of these
cooperating Witnesses are saying uh and
I think that um you've got someone like
Mark Meadows who's probably the weak
link and if you're looking for the one
witness the most likely to turn I would
vote him the most likely to turn yeah
what do you think so if this happened
what happens in the United States
because this would be a very very very
big deal
if a former president were to be
indicted
there would be a number of issues that
would have to be overcome first and
foremost
who sits on the jury and as I've said
before if you had someone like Trump in
front of a jury how do you find a jury
that is not going to be subject to
appeal because of the preconceived
notions and biases of those jurors there
are very few people in the United States
who don't have a strong opinion about
Donald Trump either for or against and
if you find the people who genuinely
don't have an opinion they are usually
acutely and painfully uninformed people
that I would also worry about having on
a jury simply due to their ability to
understand what the hell is going on if
I'm able to speak candidly with you so I
do think that the jury question is a
major major question but long before you
even got to that it's important to
understand
the framework around criminal charges
for a president of the United States
first you have to understand the legal
immunity component while a president is
President there is significant legal
immunity from prosecution for certain
actions that are taken as part of their
official duties there are disagreements
among the legal Community if not
connected to their presidential duties a
president while president went and
committed some kind of cold-blooded
murder are they subject to prosecution
you can find legal opinions on both
sides of that question but that's not
actually what we're talking about right
now and that immunity extends to certain
actions taken after a president leaves
office but how far that goes is also a
subject of legal debate there are
political considerations because the
prosecution and theoretically the
conviction of a former president on
criminal charges
is undoubtedly going to be a politicized
event and that can make it
extraordinarily difficult for
prosecutors to actually get a conviction
and if you do get one you could have
serious problems as I mentioned in terms
of who was on that jury and the jury
selection and it's very
finding someone guilty in the court of
public opinion is a very different thing
than finding legal guilt Beyond a
reasonable Beyond A Reasonable Doubt uh
in a criminal court you also have a
burden of proof issue when going after a
former president you have that in
general but in order to get a conviction
on criminal charges prosecutors do need
to establish the defendant's guilt
beyond that Reasonable Doubt in general
that's a tough standard in the American
legal system that's why we have many
acquittals but when the defendant is a
former president with access to every
resource and advisors and the best
lawyers that can also be a significant
challenge to overcome and also these
things move slowly uh Trump has been out
of office now for just short of two
years and the passage of time can make
it more difficult to secure convictions
on criminal charges if there's a lot of
distance from when the alleged crime
took place and this can be because of
inability to locate Witnesses who
remember relevant issues or a loss of
evidence or for a whole number of other
reasons and also it's important to
consider that public sentiment can
change George W bush is a good example
of this and I've been careful on this
program never to
rehabilitate George W Bush's image while
acknowledging like okay he's not as
whacked As Trump in a lot of different
ways right after George W bush left
office if you were to pull the American
public I think you would have found that
there was significant support for going
after Bush as a war criminal for his
actions related to the Iraq War my
belief is and this is just speculation
and maybe there's polling on this I
don't know that if you pulled the
country now on that exact same question
you would find much less support for
going after Bush for war crimes even
though the actions taken while he was
President don't differ now this is
different than was he immune because
these were actions taken in Iraq related
to his work it's not it's not even a
legal question it's just a public
opinion question I believe that although
the facts haven't changed since George W
bush left office
the interest from the public in going
after Bush for whatever wrongdoing he
may have participated it in would have
been greatly diminished and I do think
that the longer that this goes without
charges against Trump that is
potentially also going to be a factor so
Nick Ackerman says legal uh criminal
charges coming at the state and federal
level
we will probably soon know as so many
things are now happening at once